digamos que nos dan esta fórmula
molecular de 5 h 10
y este espectro de rm de protón y nos
dicen que determinemos la estructura de
la molécula lo primero que puedes hacer
es calcular el índice de deficiencia de
hidrógeno y entonces si tiene 5 carbonos
aquí el mayor número de hidrógenos que
podrías tener sería 2n 2 donde n es
igual a 5
5 + 2 es igual a 12
así que 12 es el mayor número de
hidrógenos aquí solo tenemos 10
hidrógenos por lo que nos hace falta dos
hidrógenos nos hace falta un par de
hidrógenos y por ende el índice de
deficiencia de hidrógeno es igual a 1
inmediatamente eso me hace pensar que un
doble enlace podría estar presente en
esta molécula o un anillo vayamos a
abajo a los valores de integración para
esta señal hay un valor de integración
de 27 para esta señal el valor de
integración es de 40.2 para esta señal
es de 28.4 y para esta señal es de 42.2
recuerda lo que debemos de hacer divides
todos los valores de integración entre
el valor más pequeña
más bajo es por supuesto 27 así que 27
dividido entre 27 es por supuesto 1
y 40.2 dividido entre 27 está bastante
cerca a 1.5 28.4 dividido entre 27 eso
se aproxima mucho a 1 y 42.2 dividido
entre 27 nuevamente se aproxima bastante
a 1.5 recuerda que estos son los números
relativos de protones dándote estas
señales pero no puedes tener 1.5
protones dándote una señal
necesitamos un número entero y tenemos
que tomar en cuenta los 10 protones en
total de x
si multiplicamos 11 por 2
entonces obtenemos 2 protones esta señal
representa 2 protones si multiplicamos
1.5 por 2 obtenemos 3 esta señal
representa 3 protones si multiplicamos 1
por 2 obtenemos 2 y si multiplicamos 1.5
por 2 obtenemos 3 si sumas todo eso dos
más tres más dos más tres esos son por
supuesto 10 protones ahora ya estamos
tomando en cuenta a todos los 10
protones utilizando nuestros valores de
integración ahora miremos cada señal una
por una empecemos con esta señal tenemos
un ch 2 ya que tenemos dos protones esta
señal representa un c h 2
cuatros protones vecinos tienen esos
protones del ch 2 podemos saber eso a
través del número de picos en esa señal
esta señal de aquí tiene 123 picos si
piensas en la regla de n 1
si tienes n vecinos obtienes n más un
picos si tenemos tres picos lo único que
tenemos que hacer es restarle 1 para
saber cuántos protones vecinos son tres
menos uno es igual a 2
estos protones del ch 2 tienen dos
protones vecinos pensemos en el
desplazamiento químico para esta señal
el desplazamiento químico de esta señal
está entre dos partes por millón y 2.5 y
eso parece ser la región para un protón
al lado de un carbón hilo y eso tiene
mucho sentido porque calculamos nuestro
i dh igual a 1 indicando que podría
haber un doble enlace presente y
necesitamos tomar en cuenta
al oxígeno en nuestra fórmula molecular
continuamos dibujando un carbón hilo y
estos protones del ch 2 están junto al
carbón y lo sabemos eso debido al
desplazamiento cierto tenemos el carbono
y el oxígeno deslinda a estos dos
protones un poco y nos da un valor mayor
para el desplazamiento químico comparado
a algo en la región tipo al que no bien
pongamos color a estos protones de aquí
en magenta digamos que esta señal es
debido a esos dos protones vayamos a la
siguiente señal tenemos tres protones
ese sería un grupo metido un ch3
los protones vecinos hay para esos
protones del metilo bueno solo hay un
pico aquí así que uno menos uno es igual
a cero
0 protones vecinos
qué pasa con el desplazamiento químico
el desplazamiento químico para esta
señal es nuevamente más de dos partes
por millón por lo que esta señal está
deslindada estos protones deberán de
estar un poco de blindados y esos
deberán de estar junto a nuestro
carbonell o dibujaremos nuestros
protones del metilo estan deslindados
por estar junto al carbón y lo y hagamos
esto azul
estos protones en la azul aquí
estos tres protones nos dan esta señal y
deberíamos esperar cero protones vecinos
esos protones están en este carbono y el
carbono de juntos no tiene protones l 0
protones vecinos tiene sentido
continuamos con la siguiente señal esta
señal representa dos protones eso es un
ch2 cuántos protones vecinos contemos
cuántos picos tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 6
picos y le restamos 16 menos 15
esperaríamos 5 protones vecinos
continuamos con la siguiente señal 3
protones y es un grupo metilo 11h
cuántos vecinos bueno tenemos un nuevo 2
3 - 1 es 2 esperaríamos 2 protones
vecinos estas dos señales de aquí esta
de aquí y esta de aquí estamos hablando
de menos de 2 partes por millón ahora
esto debe de estar lo más lejos posible
del carbón y lo cierto no están siendo
tan de brinda das como las dos señales
en esta dirección
estos dos protones vecinos para el grupo
metilo deberán ser estos dos protones de
aquí continuamos dibujando a eso tenemos
nuestros protones
metido aquí
y déjame hacer los rojos
estos protones en rojo nos están dando
esta señal
de esta señal sabemos que estos protones
del metilo están junto a dos vecinos
deberíamos de tener un ch 2 junto a ese
metido continuamos dibujando ahí nuestro
ch2
y este s a 2
este sh2 debe de ser esta señal de aquí
hablemos de cuántos vecinos esperamos
esperamos cinco vecinos para estos
protones del ch 2 simplemente contemos
los 12
455 protones vecinos concuerda con lo
que estamos viendo en el espectro de rm
n y ahora esos protones magenta y rojos
están de hecho en ambientes diferentes y
entonces la versión simplificada de la
regla de n 1 no es exactamente verdadera
pero funciona para este ejemplo así que
vamos a continuar con él porque lo único
que nos importa es obtener la estructura
de nuestra molécula
bien pensemos en los protones de en rojo
otra vez los productores en rojo deberán
tener dos vecinos cuántos vecinos
deberán tener los protones el rojo aquí
hay uno y aquí hay dos así que esto
tiene sentido
ésta también tiene sentido ya hemos
hablado de eso pensamos en los protones
magenta los protones magenta deberían
tener dos vecinos veamos al carbono
vecino de este aquí está el carbono
vecino aquí tenemos un vecino y aquí
tenemos un vecino y esto tiene sentido y
ya hemos hablado del protón azul con
cero vecinos todo parece tener sentido
aquí y para resumir asegúrate de contar
todos tus átomos y por supuesto
obtendrás 5 carbonos 10 hidrógenos y un
oxígeno cuando haces eso esta era la
estructura de puntos que intentábamos
encontrar
veamos otro ejemplo tenemos la fórmula
molecular de 8 a 10 continuamos
calculando el índice de deficiencia de
hidrógeno si tenemos 8 carbonos entonces
podríamos tener un máximo de 2 por 8 más
dos hidrógenos 2 por 8 es 16 más 2 es 18
para 8 carbonos 18 hidrógenos es lo
máximo tenemos aquí 10 hidrógenos nos
faltan 8 hidrógenos nos faltan cuatro
pares de hidrógenos por lo que el índice
de deficiencia de hidrógeno es igual a 4
recuerda que siempre que tu idea sea
igual a 4 debemos pensar en un anillo de
benceno
continuaré dibujando un anillo de
benceno aquí
y veamos la integración algunas veces
verás a la integración de esta manera
esto representa a 5 protones esta señal
con un aspecto bastante complejo esta
señal de aquí representa a 2 protones y
esta señal representa 3 protones
volvamos a estos 5 protones con esta
señal compleja esta está en el rango
aromático aproximadamente desde 6.5 a 8
esos deberían de ser 5 protones
aromáticos podemos continuar dibujando 5
protones saliendo de nuestro anillo de
benceno
y aunque esos protones estén en un
ambiente un poco diferente debido a que
el valor de integración es 5 aquí
sabemos que hay un anillo de benceno
presente y hemos acabado no nos tenemos
que preocupar por los ambientes un poco
diferentes
sabemos que estos 5 protones nos están
dando esta señal complicada de aquí
ahora veamos a esta señal dos protones
eso sería un c h 2
cuántos protones vecinos hay para éste
sh2 1 2 3 4 picos si hay cuatro picos 4
- 1 es 3
estos protones ch 2 tienen 3 vecinos
bien veamos esta siguiente señal 3
protones éste debería ser un ch 3
cuántos protones vecinos tenemos para
los protones del ch 3
uno dos tres picos tres picos
3 - uno es dos y entonces dos protones
vecinos deberían ser estos dos protones
vecinos así que continuaremos dibujando
un grupo de tilo este de aquí es un
patrón de grupo estilo aquí hay un ch2 y
aquí está tu ch3 dibujemos todos
nuestros protones
tenemos estos protones y tenemos
protones coordinamos los colores aquí
asegurémonos que todo tiene sentido
estos protones rojos de aquí deberían de
estar dándonos esta señal
estos protones del metilo esperamos dos
vecinos porque tenemos tres picos aquí
en nuestra señal y aquí están los dos
vecinos 1 y 2 2 protones vecinos veamos
a estos dos protones
después estos dos protones nos están
dando esta señal esperamos tres vecinos
porque tenemos cuatro picos 1 2 3 4
aquí está el carbono vecino
tres protones y luego este también es un
carbono vecino pero no hay protones en
este carbono y entonces solo vemos a
estos tres vecinos
así que todo parece tener sentido y
nuevamente cuenta todos tus átomos y
asegúrate de estar contemplando todo por
ejemplo aquí tienes 8 carbonos de los
cuales preocuparte por lo que en tu
anillo sabemos que son 6
456 luego tenemos 7 y luego tenemos 88
carbonos es correcto y si cuentas todo
esto tienes a tus 10 hidrógenos también
este es el espectro rm m para el
etilbenceno este fue un poco más
sencillo que el ejemplo anterior